It took me over 7 years to find the
strategy that finally made me
consistently profitable. Let me teach it
to you in under 4 minutes. Every morning
at 9:30 Eastern Standard Time, I open my
charts and look for key price action
from the overnight and the pre-market
data. Marking off key areas of support
or resistance where I think the market
is likely to reverse off of. Then I go
into a 1-minute chart of the same market
and I look for 30 minutes after the
market opens. The S&P 500 for me opens
up at 7:30, so I mark 7:45 and 8:00.
These are key times in the market where
I have consistently noticed that it will
cause a reversal in the market. And so I
like to be hyper aware of when these
times show up. Once the market opens at
7:30, I watch to see the price movement
of those first 15 minutes. Does the
market make a flush up or a flush down
into one of my support zones? And as
well as one of those reversal timings.
And if it looks like it's hitting one of
these potential timings and reversing
and bottoming and has potential to go
up, I will look for a few key factors to
enter into a trade. The four key factors
I want to see for entering into a
reversal is one, this move down into the
zone and my reversal timing, is it needs
to be a strong flush down. If the
market's all choppy and not moving
easily, it's unlikely to reverse easily.
Good trades happen in volatile markets.
Number two is the current trend that
it's in needs to be broken. Because I'm
looking for reversal trades, I'm often
betting against the current trend. But
to do this effectively, you want to
enter in when it's clear that that
current downtrend has started to break.
And so to do that, I either look at a
trend line based off of the current
trend if and when that has been broken,
or I watch the swings of the current
trend. What are the lows and the highs
doing? Once the market stops making
lower lows and lower highs and starts
making a higher low and potentially a
higher high, well, that is another key
that the trend is shifting. And then
finally going into a recording of this,
the last thing I'm looking for to
complete this head and shoulders is have
this big bullish candlestick break the
highs here. And then when that happens,
I enter in an order betting that the
market's going to go higher and I put my
stop below the previous swing low
because I'm going with the swings of the
market. [music] And then so for a
target, I'm looking to see the downtrend
get reversed all the way because when
the market moves down in such a rapid
fashion, it's an unhealthy trend [music]
and it's likely to reverse higher. And
so ideally, at a minimum, I'm going for
two times my risk or even better is
three times my risk. [music] And so I
slowly manage and target those rough
areas. And as it gets up with this
specific trade, I pretty much close out
at two and a half my profit for a little
over $4,500.
If you want a complete course that goes
into every detail in finding and
executing the strategy on basis, check
out this full course right here.